je voudrais en cinq minutes et essayez
de vous donner un argumentaire fort
précis sur la question du logement
la question du logement c'est la plus
belle des informations parisienne depuis
plusieurs années je dis bien des
informations parce que en réalité le
logement social est devenu un objet de
communication plus que de réalité
pierre-yves l'a dit tout à l'heure
depuis maintenant plus de dix ans la
ville de paris ne construit plus elle
construit beaucoup moins qu'avant
elle parle en revanche de plus en plus
de logements sociaux
elle le fait parce qu'en réalité elle a
substitué à la construction pour des
raisons sur lequel je reviendrai
elle a substitué les préemptions d'abord
les conventionnements les
conventionnements ça veut dire qu'on
transforme les sociétés d'économie mixte
qui existaient comme la sagi et la rivp
on les colle dans paris habitat et puis
on fait du de la production diffuse
c'est à dire que maintenant il ya des
zones tout entière ou la ville va
exercer son pouvoir et où elle exerce
tout ça pour faire du chiffre
pour être tout à fait net il n'y a pas
que la ville qui fait ça car si l'état
ne s'était pas lui aussi engagé dans une
politique de sru dont la droite porte
quelques responsabilités si l'état
n'avait pas lui-même fait du chiffre
nous ne serons pas au jeu nous ne
serions pas aujourd'hui obligé en
réalité de faire du chiffrage plutôt que
du logement social
ça c'est la réalité des choses quelle
est la conséquence de tout ça c'est que
nous sommes dans un dans un endroit de
dupes qui permet toutes les
manipulations médiatiques ne vous
laissez pas avoir
les chiffrages que l'on vous donne sur
le logement social n'ont rien à voir
avec la réalité des choses pour une
raison très simple c'est que les
conventionnements et les préemptions ne
change pas les habitants il ya un
roulement de 5% sur les logements qui
seront présentées ou qui seront
conventionnés mais en réalité le chiffre
global ne change pas et il change de
moins en moins pour
exemple qui sont d'ailleurs complètement
indépendante de la situation politique
1 les gens sont de plus en plus âgée et
restent dans leur appartement et par
conséquent le fait qu'il change de
statut ne change rien au chiffrage 2
malheureusement on le voit dans les
mairies iliad en plus en plus de
familles éclatent et dans ces conditions
vous avez en permanence la famille mari
qui vient parce que ça va plus et donc
elles cherchent un logement donc par
conséquent non seulement la situation du
logement social ne s'améliore pas malgré
les chiffrages mirobolant mais elle ne
peut que s'aggraver et elle s'aggrave
d'où les chiffres considérables que vous
rencontrez en ile-de-france salle 100
milles 180 milles à paris avec des
déclarations incroyable de la part de la
mairie de paris à ce sujet car la vraie
question elle n'est pas dans le logement
social
elle est en réalité dans un mode de
gestion du parc immobilier parisien
en réalité la mairie de paris
progressivement à évoluer avec delanoë
est maintenant nettement avec hidalgo
vers une stratégie qui est totalement
idéologique c'est à dire le locatif pour
tous le locatif pour tous qui n'a rien à
voir avec le social le locatif pour tout
ça signifie qu'en réalité
l'objectif de la ville de paris c'est un
petit peu ce que faisait bobigny bondy
autant bleus où les communistes étaient
à la tête de la seine saint denis
et bien désormais c'est le locatif pour
tous en réalité quel est le changement
vous avez un appartement privé cet
appartement privé et vendues et présenté
par la ville de paris
rien ne change sauf que vous avez
désormais ton prenez sur le front vous
êtes sociale vous êtes locatif social
voilà la réalité la réalité c'est que le
rêve de la mairie de paris c'est en
réalité de faire une ville complètement
locative est le vrai sujet politique
mais jamie que nous allons retrouver
très vite c'est que nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la ville n'a pas
vocation à être
le propriétaire locataire qui fait des
locataires dans toute la ville c'est une
vision totalitaire et concentrationnaire
qui effectivement a été très utilisé par
les communistes
très utilisée encore dans certaines
mairies communistes mais dont l'échangé
sont évidents parce que qu'on le veuille
ou non le fait d'être sous la tutelle
même indirect de la ville de paris qui
est qui et votre propriétaire à qui vous
devez donner référence de locataires ben
vous met dans les mains et on voit
apparaître aujourd'hui on m'a encore
citer ça hier à la mairie on voit
apparaître la deuxième stade de ce genre
de politique qui était tellement
tellement à la mode à bobigny autant
rouge c'est que au fond il y à des
clients dont on va essayer de se
débarrasser
alors c'est les petits ennuis ça
commence en disant vous avez un problème
vous êtes au dessus du niveau vous avez
un problème c'est pas payer votre loyer
c'est un problème vous n'avez eu une
fonction qui n'est pas conforme
c'est ce genre d'anti tin man permanent
la pression des associations la pression
des associations de locataires à
tendance communisante de plus en plus
présente à paris qui va faire qu'en
réalité la ville de paris non seulement
cherche un ensemble de locataires mais
qu'elle cherche en plus à exercer la
pression du locataire nous sommes dans
une phase qui est une phase politique
donc le vrai débat il est plus sûr
logement social c'est bidon tout ce
qu'on vous raconte dans la presse des
30% et faux faux jamais la ville de
paris aura fait aussi peu de logements
sociaux on dit pu construire ont dit
faire du logement social
faire du logement social ça signifie
qu'on se débrouille à mettre un numéro
supplémentaire pour faire du social mais
qu'en réalité on ne construit pas le
terme construire d'ailleurs est
abandonnée désormais des actes officiels
de la mairie de paris
donc le vrai débat c'est quoi c'est en
réalité que la ville de paris combat la
notion de propriété et notamment de
l'accession sociale à la propriété
nous sommes un peu responsable aussi je
dois dire parce que moi qui siègent à
l'assemblée depuis quelques temps
lorsque nous avons proposé alors dans
des gouvernements de droite je ne cite
personne de maître l'accession sociale à
la propriété comme élément fondamental
des pourcentages sru non c'était trop
difficile
c'était trop difficile c'est pareil que
pour le logement intermédiaire j'espère
qu'en 2017
nos gouvernants auront quand même le
courage peut-être d'intégrer à cet essai
rue des éléments essentiels de
l'accession sociale à la propriété je
l'espère je l'espère je n'en suis pas
sûr
c'est un combat c'est un combat qu'il
faudra mener vous et nous l'accession
sociale à la propriété ça signifie en
réalité qu'il faut substituer à ce
mécanisme le locatif qui est un
mécanisme qui lorsqu'il est généralisée
devient idéologique par une pression sur
l'individu une accession sociale à la
propriété
et moi je vous propose depuis plusieurs
années de mettre des milliers de
logements en vente du parc social
des milliers des milliers de logements à
des taux d'intérêt qui soient des
intérêts bonifiés dôme qui aurait des
éléments mais le représentant de la
fnaim ne dira tout à l'heure tu aurais
des éléments extrêmement positif sur le
marché parisien est en particulier qui
ferait baisser les prix mais quand on
parle à la mairie de paris de la
propriété les chiens a mis la propriété
mettez vous dans la tête c'est la
vieille devise de mars
la propriété c'est le vol tout mais pas
la propriété et nous sommes gérés par le
frère joseph car nous avons à la tête de
paris vous le savez en matière de
logement quelqu'un qui est exceptionnel
on apprit limoges qui était communiste
depuis ma barberolle l'existence de
limoges
on a tout pris mais nous à paris on a un
adjoint logement qui est communiste
c'est quand même extraordinaire mais
c'est extraordinaire et dangereux n'est
pas n'importe quel adjoint communiste en
adjoint communiste qui est fier de sa
famille stalinienne et qui d'ailleurs a
écrit un livre sur ses ancêtres
stalinien pour s'en vanter
alors vous comprendrez que j'appelle
frère joseph
car avec des individus pareil qui fonde
la com c'est celle de faire passer
l'idée que le locatif social c'est le
progrès de la société
eh bien nous retrouvons exactement la
méthode dans la mairie de moscou a été
géré
il ya presque 50 ans avec le succès que
vous savez donc là est le danger
le vrai danger mes chers amis il n'est
pas dans une querelle technique sur le
port chantage du logement social
personne n'arrivera à gérer le logement
social à paris correctement et pour des
raison très simple c'est que paris est
une ville densifier la densité de paris
est à la hauteur de shanghai est de gaza
gaza c'est une parenthèse parce que
paris est une petite ville parce que oui
ce sont les chiffres ce sont les shins
ce sont les chiffres exacts c'est comme
ça paris est une petite ville faire une
politique de densification du logement à
paris qu'ils soient propriétaires ou
locative est une erreur majeure
quand on parle de lutter contre la
pollution la pollution automobile existe
c'est clair il faut s'associer à ce qui
est fait à paris mais la pollution par
la densité est énorme au sein du
périphérique et vous ne pouvez pas
régler les problèmes de pollution sauf à
voir vraiment des produits qui sont
extraordinaires qualités sans entamer la
pollution parisienne et l'accentuer par
conséquent le grand paris est pour nous
une nécessité même si les communes
autour de paris ne le comprennent pas
encore c'est pour les parisiens une
nécessité que d'avoir cette respiration
tout autour de paris et c'est la raison
pour laquelle la région ile-de-france
est important et je souhaite que nous
prenions la région de france parce que
sur la question du logement salle des
célèbes seul moyen de libérer sept
cette étreinte rouge dans lequel paris
est en train de se mettre dans le
locatif social absolue bidon qui est en
réalité une mesure idéologique
voilà mes chers amis quelques arguments
terme et je suis prêt à se développer
dans les arrondissements les plus
difficiles de paris pour aller expliqué
au parisien
à quel point ils sont les têtards de la
politique du logement de la ville merci
claude rault